[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle émission qui
s'intitule Yve livre imaginez-vous que
nous allons parler d'un Yve Linois qui a
sorti un livre voilà on ne l'aurait pas
deviné il s'appelle Thomas Garnier
Thomas Garnier bonjour bonjour merci
d'être venu jusqu'à nous d'avoir répondu
à notre invitation c'est la première
fois qu'on a le plaisir de vous recevoir
alors on va dire tout de suite de quoi
on parle à savoir votre livre un ce
qu'on appelle un beau livre c'est un
livre de photos il y a près de 200
photos vous avez prise vous et qui
s'appelle le château de Versailles vue
du ciel alors c'est édité par Albain
Michel et en coédition avec le château
de Versailles bien évidemment voilà ça
c'est dit alors on va faire connaissance
avec vous vous êtes évidemment
photographe vous êtes êtes aussi
vidéaste vous êtes pilote de drone
certifié parce qu'il faut un diplôme on
est d'accord tout à fait ça s'acquierre
comment ça c'est un diplôme de
télépilote c'est comme le permis de
conduire donc il faut passer un code une
partie théorique et une partie pratique
d'accord comme comme la voiture comme le
bateau ok parce que à la base c'est
interdit de survoler le château de
versaill si je ne m'abuse absolument en
tout cas ça nécessite de nombreuses
autorisations pour obtenir
l'autorisation de de survoler le le
domaine parce que je me suis il y a eu
un un un clip du groupe au secours
Phenix h tout à fait de avec la
blogotèque cétait pas un drone non il
n'y avait pas de drone pour ah pardon
j'ai rien dit B nen parlons plus ok vous
êtes aussi chef du service audiovisuel
et community manager du château tout à
fait voilà depuis 2011 alors vous
participez à la création de contenu
nécessaire à l'information et à la
communication du château et depuis 2017
vous vous êtes spécialisé donc en
passant ce ce diplôme de de de de pilote
de drone dans la photo de la prise de
vue aérienne voilà alors comment ça
marche un drone qui prend des photos en
de mots c'est formidable déjà puisque ça
permet vraiment de de de prendre de la
hauteur par rapport à un lieu
gigantesque donc c'est vrai que
appréhender versaill dans dans son
ensemble c'est parfois compliqué on
prend des photos du jardin du château
mais avec le drone on peut s'élever et
essayer de de de
photographier l'ensemble du domaine h HM
donc ça élargit le spectre exactement
c'est c'est un peu comme passer de la 2D
à la 3D en jeux vidéo pour un
photographe d'un seul coup l'univers d'
possible et infini les perspectives sont
infinis les choix de cadrage sont
infinis donc c'est un vrai déjà que
versaill est un terrain de jeu
incroyable mais avec le drone c'est avec
ce jouet là en plus c'est
c'estana et donc vous voyez dans votre
main ce qui exactement mon drone est lié
à une radioc commmande que je tiens dans
les mains avec mon téléphone portable
dessus et donc j'ai un le tour caméra de
la caméra embarquée sur le drone je vois
et je dirige la caméra et le drone pour
obtenir des cadrage très rigoureux comme
le lieu impose OK et alors vous avez
donc une préface de Catherine péar là la
présidente du château bien évidemment et
bon qu'est-ce qu'elle dit ben elle dit
qu'elle é très contente et que c'est
formidable ça voilà et vous vous dites
par exemple parce qu'après il y a pas
beaucoup de textes il y a la préface de
Catherine pegar et après à votre texte à
vous hein Thomas Garnier vous dites
c'est comme si versaill avait été conçu
pour être vu du ciel alors PvE
m'expliquer un peu ce mais c'est vrai
que quand on cherche dans les archives
du château on se rend compte que les
créateurs ont conçu les parteres de
broderie les bosquets sur des plans donc
vu du ciel et avec ces photos aériennes
on retrouve finalement l'idée des plans
originaux de la la conception du domaine
et finalement ce drone il est là aussi
pour montrer Versailles
autrementd bah c'est-à-dire que versaill
c'est un lieu qui depuis la création de
la photographie a été photographié main
et main de fois VO ça ça va être une de
mes questions comment photographier un
lieu aussi déjà aussi photographié bah
c'est vrai que moi je me lève le matin
en me disant comment est-ce que je peux
montrer Versailles autrement comment je
peux essayer de faire vivre le passé
dans le présent en tant que photographe
du château de Versailles et le drone
c'est une opportunité incroyable puisque
c'est une opportunité qui permet de
faire de la la photo entre 0 et 120 m
puisque les avions et les h ne peuvent
pas descendre enessous de 150 m donc il
y a eu de la photo réalisée pas de
risque de collision exactement et donc
et la plupart des photos en fait sont
plus jolies plus ell raconte plus de
choses entre 0 et 120 m elles sont moins
haut donc on peut avoir juste des fois à
20 ou 30 m ça suffit pour avoir un une
autre un autre approche une autre vision
du lie ex les oiseaux il y a pas de
télescopage non non non alors certains
oiseaux peuvent tourner autour essayer
de l'attaquer comme les cor
oui oui ça arrive mais dans ces cas-là
on s'éloigne et c'est souvent qu'on est
proche d'un d'un nid on essaie
évidemment de déranger le moins possible
et la flore justement vous faites vos
photos j'imagine aussi par souci de de
de de nouveauté montrer des choses
neuves qu'on n pas vu à des heures
indues oui alors je je pratique la photo
aérienne surtout très tôt le matin et
très tard le soir pour avoir les
lumières les plus exceptionnelles
possibles pour avoir les lieux vides de
visite
pour pour voilà offrir des ambiances
comme sur cette photo alors là c'est
c'est une brume autonnale voilà du vous
aimez l'automne oui j'aime beaucoup
l'automne grâce à c'est la plus belle
saison levé ça c'est une photo qui est
qui est aussi assez incroyable puisque
voilà les fontaines sont allumées très
tôt le matin comment ça se fait parce
que j'ai demandé au
CH votre petite mise en scène votre
petit décor on essae on a essayé dans ce
livre en tout cas de de de compiler des
photos exceptionnelles euh donc cette
photo elle en fait partie donc ça c'est
plutôt tard le soir puisque le château
est construit sur un axe est ouest donc
le le le soleil se lève sur la façade
est du château et se couche sur la
façade ouest et donc au milieu la
galerie des glacees hm hm l'eau a une
une importance énorme dans vos photos
oui on essaie vraimentente bah dans tout
le le langage de versaill l'eau est
omniprésente et et c'est vrai que j'ai
essayé aussi de montrer ses bosquets ses
fontaines sous leur meilleur jour mais
vu du ciel en action et vu du ciel voilà
essayer de montrer ces choses qui ont
été vues 1000 fois au sol photographi
fois d'une autre manière d'une autre
approche c'est vrai que certains bosquet
ressemble à des cadranss de Monte vu du
ciel mais oui c'est incroyable il y a
des il y en a qui ressemblent certaines
photos on dirait vraiment des paysages
abstraits d'autres avec la brume plutôt
des impressionnistes euh on sait plus ce
qu'on voit quoi c'est juste une très
belle image et euh ça ça change tout
quoi c'est incroable vrai il y a la
salle des Maronniers qui vu du ciel
ressemble à un violon mais c'est c'est
ces photos aériennes elles permettent
aussi de de montrer la modernité encore
aujourd'hui de versaill d'un par de
brouterie de la géométrie en fait c'est
très graphique ça ou pu c'est resté
intact exactement c'est ça ces photos
elles sont là aussi pour rendre hommage
au travail euh des créateurs mais aussi
des gens qui entretiennent versail
aujourd'hui c'est que vous dites vous
êtes le fotorire vous passez à après
c'est ça bouta voilà en bout de chaî
pour mettre en valeur tout le travail de
toutes ces ces équipes du château alors
là qu'est-ce qu'on voit pariquement
c'est ça c'est le le hameau de la reine
et donc c'est c'estout du jardin anglais
le le lac venait d'être vidé et
rempli exactement donc il est encore
très cl très clair on dirait une lagune
ouais tout à fait et c'est et c'est vrai
que vu au sol on n pas du tout cette
impression on comprend la géométrie des
lieux ça permet aussi voilà d'avoir une
meilleure compréhension la géométrie oui
de voir d'en haut c'est bien plus simple
et il y a aussi une photo que je trouve
magnifique c'est celle où les les
barques sont
rangées le matin dans un un angle du
Grand Canal et ça aussi on peut pas
s'imaginer que c'est que c'est là quoi
c'est presque à
fable elle montre je sais pas si on l'a
en visuel toute façon faut faut regarder
ça dans ce livre ça aussi c'est sublime
c'est la cour d'honneur Cour de Marbre
Cour de Marbre voilà donc pareil qui est
très graphique hein le le le motif de
marbre fonctionne très très bien vu du
ciel il permet aussi de se rendre compte
des cours intérieurs du château de son
organisation c'est il y a aussi voilà
une petite légende en dessous chaque
photo qui essae de de traduire
l'histoire que j'ai voulu raconter sur
chaque photo ok alors vous vous aimez
vous aimez donc prendre des photos de
très haut de très profond parce que vous
faites aussi de la photo en plonger dans
un dans un caisson vous allez souvent
photographier dans des pays froids dans
des pays très chaud bref les extrêmes du
coup en quoi est-ce que ou peut-être pas
d'ailleurs le le château c'est un sujet
extrême ou pas pour
vous dans un certain sens le château de
Versailles c'est un
endroit qui demande beaucoup de de
rigueur qui demande beaucoup de
de oui enfin enfin j'ai j'ai la photo
que je fais pour versaill et la photo
que je fais un peu plus
personnellement la photo les photos des
pays froids j'aime beaucoup mais voilà
j'aime bien aussi traduire cette passion
dans les photos d'un versa en neiger ou
ou en fait j'essaie d'être le
photographe être un photographe le plus
polyvalent possible que ça soit à
versaill ou ailleurs pour moi faire de
la photo aérienne de la photo
sous-marine de la photo de portrait de
la photo de reportage ça fait partie de
de ce que j'aime faire de de rester le
plus polyvalent possible et parce qu'à
versaill c'est tellement un terrain de
jeu inépuisable que finalement on fait
de tout c'est un lieu vraiment très
vivant où il y a toujours des nouveautés
en terme de restauration en terme
d'exposition en terme
d'acquisition en terme de saison aussi
puisque on suit le château de versaill
aux quatre saisons et ça je trouve que
château de versaill je sais pas si c'est
un lieu extrême mais c'est un lieu où à
mon sens il faut il faut bien connaître
son sujet pour en en dcelé la
substantifique mis exactement mais
justement vous mavez l'air de bien
connaître parce que vous avez mis
combien de temps à le le constituer
c'est un travail de sur combien d'années
alors c'est un travail de 5 ans euh
puisque j'ai eu mon mon diplôme de
télépilote il y a 5 ans et donc j'ai
commencé à survoler mais c'est vrai
qu'auparavant j'ai été médiateur
culturel au château de Versailles en
2008 et ça m'a permis de bien connaître
les lieux l'intérieur comme l'extérieur
l'intérieur comme l'extérieur et alors
là justement pour enevenenir à
l'intérieur il y a il y a des photos de
comment les les souterraines carrément
oui donc on voit l'alimentation en eau
c'est cela alors je sais pas si on les a
en alors le drone il c'est connu au
plafond
là passé alors on a exceptionnellement
il y a quand même quelques photos qui
ont été pris au sol dans ce livre ne
serait-ce que pour mettre en perspective
la vue au sol et la vue en l'air sur
certains bosquets d'accord et euh c'est
vrai que c'était un peu un prise
personnelle de vouloir montrer un lieu
caché montrer versaill autrement encore
une fois c'est vraiment la philosophie
de ce livre vous aimez les escaliers
aussi hein c'est côté graphique c'est
quoi c'est le côté graphique exactement
le côté moderne moi je trouve que c'est
un château qui a traversé les années
mais voilà dans un parterre de broderie
dans un sol en marquetterie de marbre
pas il y a il y a une il y a une
modernité au château bon ah je suis
dessus mais je sais pas si ça va rendre
quelque chose voilà donc c'est des vues
souterraines c'est les voilà c'est des v
donc là on est un petit peu pas très
loin du sol voilà mais c'est
impressionnant j'ai mis deux photos
animalières aussi à la fin oui alors on
va on va y arriver les deux photos al
j'ai l'impression parce que vous dites
que c'est donc consacré aux château de
Versailles mais aussi au domaine de
marlee oui tout à fait voilà alors
j'avais l'impression que le domaine de
Marley il c'est un peu plus libre libre
cours à à la sauvagerie à la nature et
et que c'était moins justement moins
cadré architecturel parlant et cetera
même pour les jardins et du coup on
découvre bah des animaux sauvages voilà
oui à marli c'est c'est un lieu où qui
est comme le jardin de Versailles un
lieu où il y a des statues mais c'est un
lieu qui a qui a
plus voilà un
côté sauvage il y a du des bois il y a
énormément de de bois et de forêts à
Marle à traversé donc de faune donc il y
a eu cette année une une nombreux
chevreuil que je me suis empressé
d'aller photographier mais c'est vrai
qu'on a on a fait des photos du domaine
de Marley vue du ciel et ce qu'on
voulait c'était mettre le pendant au sol
de ce qui se passait au sol et les
photos du domaine de marlie vu du ciel
elles sont très différentes du des
photos du château c'est le même principe
de prise de vue oui mais après les
sujets mais voilà l'esthétique des deux
des deux
jardins nont pas rien à voir parce que
ils sont quand même issu de des mêmes
concepteurs mais mais c'est vrai que
étant donné que le château de Marle a
été détruit
euh on est sur un
parc
oui plus plus je sais pas comment dire
mais bah plus livré à la nature moi je
trouve ça c'est un côté plus sauvage on
a l'IM que la main de l'homme est un peu
moins présente il y a une identité il y
a une identité différente à Marley il y
a beaucoup
de de de de sportif qui courent mais
comme autour comme autour du grand canal
mais ça va être interdit bientôt je CIS
sportif j' trop non euh c'est pas drôle
bon alors le la série pour ma dernière
petite question la série bosquet de la
colonade il y a plusieurs photos on est
d'accord et alors c'est différentes
saisons différentes heures comment vous
avez pratiqué cette ces
images en 5 ans j'essayais de passer un
peu au-dessus de de de tous les bosquets
des jardins et de faire des séries
correspondant à toutes les saisons et et
aussi d'essayer de ob tenir des lumières
différentes pour toujours améliorer le
cliché puisqu'on peut toujours on peut
toujours faire mieux on peut toujours
faire différent euh une belle photo
c'est une belle lumière un beau cadrage
être au bon endroit au bon moment donc
bah ça se c'est une recherche en fait
c'est une recherche j'essaie
de de faire correspondre de raconter des
histoires donc dans dans ces photos et
de faire correspondre un peu l'identité
du lieu avec donc qui est très porté par
le soleil par les saisons puisque Louis
XIV est le Roi Soleil le soleil dicte
les saisons donc il y a beaucoup
d'illustrations des saisons dans le
jardin que que ce soit des illustrations
statuaires ou ou ou tout simplement
naturelle et et je trouve que c'était
intéressant de de créer ce dialogue
notamment autour du bosquet de la
colonade puisque le bosquet de la
colonade c'est c'est le dieu des enfers
qui qui qui qui va qui raconte la la son
enlèvement de Proserpine la fille de de
de ces la DESS des saisons h h et en
fait c'est ce qui va c'est cet événement
qui va dicter les saisons puisque quand
ces ces va geler les cultures et ensuite
un arrangement va être trouvé et donc
elle pourra avoir sa fille quelques mois
de l'année donc ça sera l'été et
quelques mois de l'année elle sera avec
Pluton donc c'est l'hiver et entre le
temps il y a l'automne et le printemps
qui est le moment de l'attente euh donc
le printemps et le moment de l'automne
où elle sait que sa fille va va repartir
dans les enfers et donc vraiment ce
bosquet il a une il a il parle des
saisons et le montrer au qure saisons
c'était pour moi quelque chose de
d'important bah oui évident Thomas
Garnier un grand merci c'est passionnant
passionnant de vous écouter et puis
passionnant et et surtout magnifique de
de regarder ce ce livre qui est voilà
qui est ench enchanteur je vous remercie
voilà les photos sont sublimes et ça
donne vraiment envie de de plonger
dedans j'en perds ma voix Thomas garni à
bientôt j'espère avec plaisir merci au
revoir à tous merci de nous avoir
suivi